the noise the din it went right the way
through all those fans and there was
important people out there lots of them
yeah I just am so grateful I never take
it for granted you know they're so loyal
and so passionate incredible they're all
so talented way they're all so diverse
in their appeal I mean it's like putting
together any group that the compliments
one another but far from giving them
advice there so assured and their talent
I'm thinking maybe they should give me
some advice I can use it then otherwise
JJ would not have picked them because
there's so much talent there that's
Oscar and George took that idea of
having the family dog who's so beloved
being intelligent enough to fly a
spaceship and plus he's a gentle soul
but he's incredibly powerful so there's
all of those elements he's just like a
dream creature been together and
everybody loves Chuy and I didn't
believe in wookies until I met Peter
Mayhew this he's a real life working a
big bookie yes
you